hey everyone
uh I'm uh gav sugomonian I'm a co-author
of aim stock so aim stack is a is an
open source ecosystem of machine
learning tools we are mainly focused on
uh building uh experiment tracking tools
or machine learning metadata tools for
researchers so a it's called aim it's
open source and we are being used in a
good number of large companies so so I'm
excited here today to share a little bit
of the knowledge and insight that we
have learned while working with many
teams while building aim
um mainly around machine learning
metadata and how to think about it uh
what's the role of machine learning
metadata in ml infrastructure
yeah and this rather strange name of my
talk is an uh homage to a book
quite an influential book called
structure and the interpretation of
computer programs so in this talk
we are gonna talk about different
versions of software like software 1.0
software 2.0
we're going to talk about ml systems as
a representation of software 2.0
um we're going to talk about machine
learning metadata as a consequence of ml
systems we're going to talk about how
the metadata is generated how it's being
used and what the metadata's impact over
over the ml systems going forward
and so hence the the title of my talk
the structure and interpretation of
machine learning so we are going to uh
hopefully quite comprehensively cover at
a level we can do in 40 minutes uh the
the machine learning metadata topic
so basically what's the software 1.0
right it has it has at its fair share of
development so five years ago there was
this famous stock called smug so if if
you if if you're aware it used to be
these different types of Open Source
tools like uh spark misos akka was a you
know uh
you know a library that was you know for
for streaming right Cassandra and Kafka
and then you know as the software
evolved then it becomes [ __ ] stock so
another software 1.0 version where misos
got replaced by kubernetes uh
essentially essentially you know this is
a system large-scale system that would
allow you to build a pretty uh you know
software that could handle a ton of
requests a ton of data in all sorts of
ways obviously nowadays people are doing
data Lakes you know a bunch of different
bigger Data Systems what's the software
1.0 has been evolving to a with a
certain Pace
um there has been other viewpoints you
can also build a like a relatively
simpler software with say tools like the
ones uh you know shown over there so uh
however however since uh five to six
years ago this new notion of software
have been evolving which Andre carpati
kind of famously coined during I think a
few years ago when he was sharing some
of the stuff that they were building at
Nvidia as software 2.0 he even went as
far as telling that software 2.0 is
going to eat software 1.0 uh rather
controversial take but a hot take but
yeah essentially and this is a this is
an this is an image from his slide where
basically was talking about some of the
machine learning systems that they have
been building a Tesla to to tackle the
the the the autonomous vehicle problem
the
so
there's also there's different hot takes
about software 2.0 for instance hogging
face co-author and CEO Clem loves to say
that the the machine learning is the
totally new way of building Tech uh
as if machine learning is not built on
top of software 1.0 but anyway so uh so
this this notion of software 2.0 going
to completely change the way we build
Tech is is kind of establishing itself
and and so basically software 2.0 uh
what is software 2.0 right so it's a
it's a set of software you know
components that together along with
machine learning uh it just comprises a
different type of system that solves a
problem that for instance offered 1.0
couldn't solve like uh recognizing
images you know making decision based on
that working with unstructured data like
text like audio and essentially and
basically these are systems mainly built
around machine learning models and
mainly built around building machine
learning models because in order to use
a machine learning model you need to be
able to build those models and so how do
you organize all of these things so
income ml systems right so
uh basically the ml system has all sorts
of different interpretations based on
who you're talking to and the company
you're talking to the engineer you're
talking to so for instance metaflow
which is a which is a pipeline tool out
of Netflix
their kind of go-to pipeline is the
following you start your project you can
kind of you know get started with play
with data Etc and then essentially you
go through different you know phases
right you transform your data you
prepare your data set then you train
your model then you test your model and
then you deploy your model and then
maybe repeat yeah so this ml system
version by metaflow there is another
very famous person uh like chip huyan
who
um loves to talk about real-time machine
learning which is oh suppose you have
built the model every time when you
build the model it it's it's a certain
cost right you're going to have some
gpus that are going to use for your
model you're gonna uh use those gpus
it's not so cheap and so how about we
keep training model why the new data
comes into our system and so basically
this is the real-time machine learning
right and so they're building I think at
their company they're building like
streaming systems that are you know
basically they're their view of machine
Learning System is around continuously
improving models without spending so
much resources and it's also the update
time is you know different than regular
machine Learning System nowadays where
there is a batch versus streaming right
so patch prediction versus stream
prediction
so it's a little bit of a different
Paradigm right but so this is another
way of thinking about machine learning
system and then there is this famous
diagram right where the the Google
basically this diagram created the whole
envelopes industry so everybody who have
been building any type of ml at the time
uh like maybe 2016 they went so they had
a certain level of pain right if you
build machine Learning Systems you
understand oh my God this is totally
different from what I was used to with
software 1.0 because I write the code
it's deterministic and then uh you know
I type something it works I type
something it works right and then with
ML it's different maybe you build a
model but then after you build the model
then how what do I do with this and how
do I update the model how do I make this
not make me waste my time right and so
this diagram is a famous Google paper
that kind of show oh the code is just a
small part of the machine learning
infrastructure unlike the software 1.0
where the code is almost everything
right so
yeah so this I I'd say this all created
the envelopes industry
um yeah so this is another view of a
machine learning systems or
infrastructure
um and this is a little bit of our like
modest take on Pipeline obviously we
have taken out some of the belts and
whistles of what modern machine learning
infrastructure would have such as
feature stores such as model stores
there is a lot more component to it but
at its core machine Learning System
nowadays is like a type of a pipeline
where basically you get your data and
then you take take a build a model and
take it up until to production and hope
it works basically and then even then if
you're if you're a little bit more
advanced maybe you also monitor on the
production so but
practice shows that not many companies
do it because it's just uh just you know
takes iterations time you know things
take building things take time so okay
so this is a typical ml system right a
pipeline
um
and then and then once you start to go a
little bit more advanced with your
systems the loops get get to be
introduced right so for instance you
want to make it easy to uh to do the
train pre-process Loop for instance you
have pre-processed a certain version of
data you want to train a model and then
uh
for instance you took that you know some
of the results from the model used some
other way of pre-processing data and
build a new model and then compare them
right so different Loops get easily get
introduced when actually trying to build
more advanced uh you know machine
learning systems
and and more Loops can be Engineers for
instance what if you so you have this
promote layer once once you build your
model you evaluate it and then you need
to decide whether to promote it to
production for instance and so
and so once you deployed maybe maybe uh
maybe and then once the data hits your
model maybe you want to revert back and
bring up the the the other model that
was there because this new model it
doesn't do well for real data right so
for instance data drift you know uh the
data drift metric doesn't doesn't show
like good results and so this there are
all sorts of Loops that's possible to
create in inside the machine learning
infrastructure and so this is unlike any
of the software 1.0 paradigms and we can
go even while their stuff there's all
sorts of things can happen because you
may not build one model you may build
several models that are interconnected
like a pipeline of models right so uh
there is levels doing machine learning
infrastructure
um
cool so what's ml metadata uh I guess
one of the early easiest examples of
machine learning metadata is basically
when you track your training right so
why do you track your training because
uh building models is hard models are
fairly stochastic you know beings and so
once you're trying training your model
uh you cannot read the model which is a
which is a set of numbers you cannot
read and say oh it's working or you
cannot debug it you cannot make any
sense of those numbers like fairly right
unless it's a very small model
uh so therefore you need to track a lot
of information about the model you need
to track a lot of information about the
training of that model and so hence come
the the training tracking and so uh not
only that but also training no training
uh runs growing numbers so you easily
end up running lots of training runs
which makes it even harder to understand
which model to pick how to understand
which model to use right and it's very
easy to waste gpus for instance uh uh
every every one of us does checkpoints
right what if you uh what if you have
been um
what if you always go back to the
previous checkpoint so any any anything
basically any uh
any anything trained by like that revert
from the previous checkpoint is a wasted
GPU and the training runs at its core
are multi-dimensional which means uh
they they could have hundreds of
parameters describing them so so it's
fairly large problem if you have
hundreds of this then you're basically
you need to have figure out a way to
compare them so um great so okay what is
ml metadata and what is examples of it
so for instance when it comes to
experiments there is lots of moving
pieces
uh basically this this these moving
pieces move all at the same time it's
not like you know sequential so code
changes all the time you tweak uh one
parameter you run a new run there you go
code changed you tweak one parameter
that's going to access a different data
version another changing data uh maybe
you your your you change your training
diagram for instance could that driver
got updated right uh model architecture
you decided to dump the the previous
architecture now you're going to use new
architecture so hyper parameter tuning
which is a description of Change by
itself so uh and basically as a result
we get like thousands of training runs
hundreds of metrics per run uh hundreds
of hyper parameters per run so this just
introduced a large large amount of
dimensionality to to you just just the
small part of the process which is just
training the models we're just talking
about training the models and nothing
else at this stage so basically how you
keep track of these changes that's where
ml metadata comes in basically this this
is all a description of a type of an ml
metadata so
so usually what we have seen people
track in these types of scenarios they
track the hardware driver basically
track everything that moves in the
system Hardware drivers versions
packages dependencies GPU performance
node performance there's for instance
for GPU performance there is I will I
can bring 10 different you know metrics
from starting from temperature up until
like the driver memory all sorts of
things you can track we have seen people
track stuff with data so for instance
with data right uh
when you're when we are for instance
talking about data pre-processing in
many cases these days data
pre-processing is another type of
machine learning process for instance
semi-supervised you know methods right
so which means you run model over new
data you generate new data Etc but which
generates new versions generates
basically new sources of data new
samples new annotations right and the
code obviously changes as well and then
apart from this you end up tracking a
lot of information about your model
which is images
metrics hyper parameters text whatever
is your problem so this is just still
still the training training tracking
um
so what is ml metadata
so training tracking actually gives a
decent idea about ml metadata is because
at every point in the in the pipeline
that I've showed similar type of data
gets tracked right
um so at pre-processing as I just
mentioned you may end up easily tracking
a very similar type of you know metrics
versions of the data uh why because you
need to have an idea for instance how
your synthetic data generation works so
so that it's somehow connected to your
training and then evaluation is another
set of metrics you're going to track and
up until the production monitoring you
still track lots of metrics basically
you try to track as much information as
possible about
anything ml
to make sense of things sometimes
locally like training and sometimes end
to end because uh because these things
are costly so you want to be on top of
them ah so basically ml metadata it
could be of two types like dictionaries
so dictionaries are uh things that
describe the dimensions of your for
instance machine learning machine
learning training like your hyper
parameters are are an example of that
your data version are an example of that
your uh for instance your system uh
environment you know parameters are a
version of that
um and so it also describes the
differences between you know uh these
different you know uh like training runs
or the evaluation runs or the
pre-processing runs right and then the
sequences is basically the metrics and
the sequences of images right so
basically roughly there are kind of two
types of things you could track in the
machine learning infrastructure as a
metadata that fairly describes your
processes
so how people use ml metadata currently
um
so obviously we've talked about the
training tracking which is model
debugging mainly it's being used for
comparing lots of these training runs so
comparing training runs is uh one uh is
one heavy application of metadata like a
very instant application of machine
learning metadata where researchers
daily need to do that but it's just only
part of it production monitoring now
there is like I don't know 10 companies
that are just doing data drift a type of
a data drift you know right out there
Fiddler AI only
amplitude and evidently yeah so just
number of them open source closed source
so it's a it's an it's another type of a
hot problem model evaluation uh like
country there is a there is this Loops
are being built right there's also you
know a lot of a lot of development on
this area so these are all type of
machine learning metadata currently
being used by by the by different
companies
um so what's the difference basically so
so somebody could ask a very valid
question of okay great so you're talking
about this machine learning metadata
thing but we have been tracking like
software for ages like we have
production logs you know we have been
you know basically what's the why do why
is it different why machine learning
metadata is uh different from like
software 1.0 logs right so there's a
bunch of different tools out there like
Prometheus datadog your your your
terminal right so these are all tools
you could use to track stuff
um so the fundamental difference uh is
that
um so what does it mean to build
software 1.0 what does it mean to build
software 2.0 so when you're building
software 1.0 it's a deterministic
process where you it's not like a blog
post you expect to write code and you
expect it to work in a certain way and
then you repeat right and uh usually
people log and try to log everything
possible as possible about the software
1.0 when it hits the production so that
they they don't expect things to not
work and so they try to lock so that
whenever it doesn't work they could go
back and understand why and kind of fix
it and keep expecting that it will work
basically right so that's one of the
main functions of tracking uh stuff for
like software 1.0 in production uh
and essentially the most importantly the
development cycle and software 1.0 is
oriented around the code
uh basically the code is source of the
truth for software 1.0 the development
is determined and the most important
their their tools are basically their
IDs and all sorts of virtual
environments and like these these types
of tools and most expensive
infrastructure actually goes to
production so people don't build on
there like unless in specific
circumstances usually the most expensive
metal hardware goes for production for
scalability and all uh obvious reasons
so they try to track everything on
production
and so
what what's what does the ml metadata
mean in this context right so there are
different tools that track machine
learning metadata in many different
contexts so again the difference is the
building ml right building ml so machine
learning by itself by nature is a
non-deterministic thing where you write
the code and then you
um
you are not sure if it will work
actually that's at the core right there
is and then there's many ways it cannot
not work uh not may not be done right uh
maybe there is a bug for instance if you
have an issue at software 1.0 it's going
to throw an error or maybe the output
won't be right if you for instance use a
matrix in machine learning model and
then somehow accidentally transpose that
like a square metrics and just use the
transpose of that Matrix accidentally in
your code you're screwed like you're
it's going to be hard like no error is
going to be thrown none of that so how
do you know if you have I don't know a
typo right a square metrics and the
transpose of it so the the issues don't
happen like naturally in basically
software 2.0 and so there therefore like
you need to figure out a way to gather
the insights about your process right
how like how do you know if like things
are not looking right so therefore in
the process it's a site-oriented
decision making it's not like a white
box or input output input output right
error strong warning strong
um
and basically what it makes ml metadata
is a development tool actually as
opposed to just the log right because
it's literally what you work with
because it's what you have anyway this
is what you only can use to understand
what's going on with your model while
building the model
um yeah and so basically code and data
alone do not produce the good models
it's the math it's the researcher
looking at the at the metadata it's the
it's all of them together and so and
to bring another parallel the most
expensive infrastructure is actually
used for development for machine
learning because uh I don't know if you
have heard gpus are not cheap so
basically what things you can do with ML
metadata
now that we have established that the ml
metadata has a role in machine learning
development a little bit more advanced
than in software these types of logs
have been software 1.0 what can you do
with machine learning metadata so for
instance uh and now that we are talking
about this wider sense of machine
Learning Systems we can use machine
learning metadata to visualize AI
pipelines right because it's generated
basically all all across the machine
learning you know pipeline we can
connect different tools together we can
use it for governance what is the
governance you want to see
how you started to build your mother up
until production and backwards that's
that's what so the whole way and then
you want to have basically this whole
tree of things you have done it's also
known as lineage uh also and
reproducibility you want to easily
connect your uh uh your
your metadata view to to the pipeline
tools to to the resource tools that
would allow you to reproduce the same
run you have had while training you know
a previous version of your model
and the compute efficiency there is all
sorts of ways you can make your gpus not
be wasted
um
heuristics over like oh when the metrics
become XYZ
stop the training change the high
performer Etc
um
you can obviously
make your model perform better uh
you can actually Define new metadata
types to help that even further so
suppose you're a computer vision
researcher and um
for instance you're tracking the you're
you're solving like you're solving a
problem where you um
uh like webcom webcam like computer
vision problem where it wants to uh say
which direction of your eyes are looking
at for some reason right uh like in
order to really understand your model
you need to maybe track like a specific
type of images where like you see your
angle of your eye because maybe that
would be the stuff that you're tracking
for your specific problem and so these
are new types of metadata that that's
not a metric that's not a regular image
that's not a text so new things may need
to to make you may need to have to make
you know analysis or like just make
better models faster and so obviously
integration with python and compute
tools and a compute tool would be for
instance a kubernetes or less alarm uh
how do you because these compute tools
they represent the environment which
also could change during you know
different runs of your you know training
so these are all these all generate
machine learning metadata and so this
shows basically that machine learning
metadata is the glue for the machine
learning infrastructure
which means it's uh this thing that
connects different tools together right
if you have a hyper parameter tuning
tool that you want to connect with your
data pre-processing tool
one of the ways to understand how your
data came in and this model got selected
is basically look look at the machine
learning metadata in Us in different
formats
um and I I was supposed to have a
visualization here where the these gaps
are filled like gray something that's
the metadata but yeah I imagine that's
that that's the one
um
uh yeah and so basically all these
complex systems are to be connected with
machine learning metadata and so this is
this is uh the kind of interpretation of
machine learning metadata in ml systems
and so machine learning but I did a lot
of ml systems basically uh is generated
everywhere uh they're all connected with
each other
all these different metadata why because
you want to keep track of things as much
as possible because while building ml
you spend your most expensive
infrastructure
uh
and it's a development tool for machine
learning from data
pre-processing to model deployment
machine learning systems are stochastic
and non-deterministic which means that
you need to track everything that moves
and so the way the way machine Learning
Systems could go to could be going
forward is
you know there is a stack of tools
connected by Machine learning metadata
so at the at the bottom there is
Frameworks then there is resource
managers where you slam kubernetes Ray
pytorch lightning everything that helps
you deal with the number of gpus
uh or CPUs in that matter so pipeline
management tools like air meta flow
flight air flow feature stores model
stores production packaging and
acceleration tools and machine learning
metadata that just connects this this
together
and so this is our hot take for machine
Learning Systems in the future
and I'm happy to take in some questions
thank you very much
anything
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Applause]